ein erstes live gruppenbild mit allen
geretteten die fußball jungs in thailand
die nach vielen tagen aus einer höhle
gerettet worden waren haben am mittwoch
das krankenhaus in chiang rai verlassen
die zwölf jungen und die
assistenztrainer trafen an einem gebäude
der verwaltung der provinz chiang rai 1
und gaben eine erste pressekonferenz
die behörden in thailand präsentierten
die 13 jungen fußballer damit erstmals
live und komplett der weltöffentlichkeit
die geretteten schilderten einige ihrer
persönlichen eindrücke nicht zuletzt der
erste kontakte und die ersten worte mit
den britischen tauchern welche die
vermissten kinder am 2 juli in der höhle
gefunden hatten waren ein thema am 23
juni war die gruppe jugendlicher bei
einem ausflug in eine große höhle im
norden thailands von einer sturzflut
überrascht wurden die fußballer zogen
sich auf der flucht vor den wassermassen
immer weiter in die höhle zurück und
wurden eingeschlossen
danach galten sie mehr als eine woche
als vermisst nach rund 17 tagen dann
waren alle zwölf kinder und ihr trainer
aus der überfluteten höhle gerettet
worden